you know it's about right away she sent
me out on bootleg cast podcast
yo boolay cab show special guest in here
his new album is out been one it's going
crazy
uh you just dropped that man you drop a
hell of visuals one of the hottest
artists on the planet right now man
Fresh Off tour Rilo Rodriguez I
appreciate yourself we have a lot in
common you and I each have a white
grandfather you do I mean I'm white so
oh yeah
I saw you talking about your granddad
and like uh how you grew up you kind of
like was like a big part of like you
know holding down the family and [__]
right yeah yeah
what is your like exact makeup
ethnically because when I see Rodriguez
I'm thinking like Dominican but then I
heard you got a white Granddad and I'm
like okay what is it what do you uh
what's your ethnicity
uh it's a really black
uh what's up man how you feeling how
first of all shout out to uh I saw the
LA show look crazy yeah they're so lit
uh you guys were just in the bay
what's this like what's the arena tour
Vibe like compared to you doing like a
because you know you'll go to the club
get the brown bag get the back end and
then you know you can go and do a a
whole damn Arena like what is what is
the energy difference for you and how do
you approach like each each situation
when it comes to performing
and I said God you gotta go do it but
like
the difference like
I don't know like ml people yeah some
more people
it's like most people know your songs
but it is different from the club though
you get nervous like doing the arena
[__] yeah I'd be nervous everything
doing clubs every time for real I still
get nervous yeah but when you get up
there and you'll be nervous when you
walk out there it goes away camera yeah
go straight away wow that's dope you
still get nervous because you're having
but again like you're getting nervous
listen getting less and less yeah yeah
yeah a good lesson that [__] crazy it's
wild too because like you know I feel
like everybody get nervous everybody
should get nervous I think it's
important once you stop getting nervous
I feel like you stopped caring you know
right yeah because you just go out there
and just you're nervous because you care
what people care think about you right
yeah you want them to receive you the
right way
um yo what's up with these dice games
bro and how much do I need to get into
one of them if I pull up well I saw the
video
we know somebody who showed up right oh
yeah I know them we knew we knew one of
the Armenian dudes that were there and
from what I understand he he left 100K
less rich
some pretty serious money getting thrown
around yeah yeah so you're not the
Gambler I ain't The Gambler you're just
kind of there for moral support now
again you was throwing the dice yeah
I've been getting them later but I don't
come like that though how much money did
you win or lose playing at that dice
game that we all saw recently
I don't even know
if I want that murder were you up or
down not one bro so you were up yeah
probably like eight bands that's great
but the other night I was losing to the
same folk really yeah foreign what's
your worst night in terms of losing
not what you mean like like how much is
the most you lost in one night gambling
and I got to bet what I was down like 20
down 20 that's right and you got it
better I bet on James Harden to win a
game Christmas four years ago
yeah and and forever like James is the
homie though shot to James
forever I just remember like my my
Christmas was ruined because the Rockets
couldn't beat the warriors with nobody
it was when everybody was injured so I
was like
everybody was injured on the Warriors
Christmas Day Rockets had like the best
record in the league oh Jesus a terrible
time worst Christmas of my life all
right yeah uh man it's crazy too because
like you I feel like
what I appreciate about how you kind of
got like viral was like sampling going
in over like classic beats right and I
feel like you're kind of the first
artist that really at least in this
generation that really did that and did
it like the right way right now
everybody is just jumping on old [__]
hey crazy you see that yeah but you were
kind of like the first guy to do it you
did it in your own way though it wasn't
like so like when you see it kind of
because you obviously influenced the
game a lot without maybe the recognition
but like when you see that like do you
recognize like man I really kind of
influenced a lot of this [__] yeah yeah
in my homeboy we were talking about that
yeah what inspired you to like
originally start doing that
so I wanted to redo it mm-hmm
yo you're from mobile right yeah
that's right near like Florida right
so I've driven through mobile like four
times because I used to live in Tampa
and I would drive from Tampa to my
hometown of Phoenix like each time I
moved so we'd stop in Mobile for like
gas and [__] and uh it's kind of like a
weird little pocket of the country
because you're like not far from New
Orleans to no you're like two hours from
the right and then you got parts of
Florida you got Tallahassee Pennsylvania
Mississippi exactly like for you growing
up and like I'm sure like uh you know
there's some legendary Alabama artists
recipes to Dopey shout out to Yellow
Wolf who's from Gadsden but like uh what
what were your influences being from
there because I'm sure you pulled from a
lot of the places near you someone like
music yeah music yeah like what were you
bumping like who kind of helped you know
form your style you would say in terms
of you just like listening to them
Adobe
it's a dude I ain't seen now from over
here
yeah
it's like a lot of local artists
Dopey was hard bro he was the one like
[__] big and like we didn't even get to
really eat anything to scratch the
surface no he didn't he got it
and uh he was a wonderful did you ever
have you ever heard of this group
um when I was a kid there was a group
from Alabama I'm not sure what part but
they're called Dirty
there's two guys called dirty and they
had like videos on BT
I think they might have been unravel
that I could be wrong but they were they
were the first time guys I ever ever
remember like Yeah from Alabama yeah and
then I mean yellow you ever [__] with
yellow wolf the white boy he's from I
heard him he was assigned to Eminem
yeah what do you because I do feel like
Alabama as a whole like over the last I
don't know six seven years you guys have
had like a real run right thinking guys
like you no cap uh young blue I'm gonna
go on and on and on right what do you
think it is about
Alabama right now that's kind of like
cutting through finally
could everyone like who won like um
I mean like it wasn't nobody from from
Alabama yeah you really gonna you're
gonna need somebody like
you kind of need somebody somebody right
yeah to open the door who do you think
open the door
I want to say like
for a person
Goose man from Alabama Gucci's from
Alabama no [__] idea this is Gucci
man this is new to me yeah you know blue
Blue's been killing it right
yeah yeah
you and Kappa definitely
a lot of food
that's a lot of book yo I wonder when I
hear your [__] what is your writing
process like or do you write or do you
go in to do the melody first like yeah
huh
but like at home the whole song
right and I'm telling you I'm telling
him to keep that and I'll just put words
in so that yo yo First Take is just
strictly strictly how I feel and I
always go with the first one I feel fire
and I hear from there you probably put
the words whatever I'm humming I just
make it worse yeah but I might start
right here and I might go to the end but
the middle might be over
um so I really record like it's kind of
weird really weird I might start at the
end
and then go back to the front oh really
yeah that's dope yeah it just depends on
how you feeling I do that every time so
you start at the end I start right here
first I might start first then I might
let it beep I might go to the end
that [__] crazy I never heard that yeah
it really it I really like recording I
don't know
um because you'll be stuck on one part
you don't want to be stuck right there
so if you stuck
right yeah some people just get stuck
and then they don't even get past them
kill your Vibe you're a dip
so I had to go and get out the way it go
it's actually really efficient all right
yeah because like you said if you have
like some sort of like writer's block or
you're right like I already got the
front and the end done so right you're
gonna have to do the middle they got to
do the middle at that point or you at
least gonna come back to it I'll do it I
like that yo talk to me what has been
your favorite experience on tour so far
just short performing but like has there
been a city or like a maybe an after
party or something like man this city
was just crazy everything like to a fun
it's a it's a super fun but yeah every
city been lit though what's the bus life
like
tour bus oh I'm gonna feel better in
your bed well I heard you're not allowed
to [__] on the bus is that true hell now
I mean you can't do that but I heard
that they they try to be like if you can
wait don't [__] on the bus I ain't even
never [__] on the bus yet but
amazing [__] on the bus I'm sure if you
got to go you got to go that's why it's
there they ain't still in there like
that though they told you that I every
rapper I know it's like maybe they're on
less nicer buses but they're always like
yo
the driver prefers nobody shits on the
bus because then he's got to clean this
[__] oh yeah I forgot about that so like
usually there's like you know we hit hit
a [__] liquor store or a truck stop
or something all right all right so yeah
what I always hear that couple of things
that people need on tour or that they're
always short on are draws and socks is
this true yeah
it'll be on the club those are like the
the Necessities right like you got you
can never have too many socks and draws
on the tour bus are you guys playing 2K
or any uh any PS5 hey man crowd dude
Call of Duty
if you are a playable character in Call
of Duty which is very possible one day
what's your like go-to gun
that look golden yellow gold and stick
golden or golden AK do the golden AKA
I feel like you could like next year we
might be like playing as Ryan Rodriguez
on Call of Duty right you could it's
okay they just dropped Nikki Nikki yeah
Nikki and 21 Savage I didn't see each
one isn't it 21 times yeah both of them
yeah so two you'd be both of them I
didn't see that imagine like getting
smoked by Nicki Minaj though bro like
you're like running around and Nikki's
[__] in her pink like camo [__] you
get capped by Nicki
know how to play though no I'm not even
talking about that it'd be like a
nine-year-old kid with a headset yeah oh
yeah I forget they playing at it yeah oh
yeah I like [__] man can you pick
somebody else bro to kill me with what
um who's your go-to on uh 2K Madden
uh
the books the Bucks yeah man yeah
Eagles are great because you just run
you can run though because Jalen hurts
is a monster it's almost like did you
ever play back in the day when Mike Vick
was in Madden were you old enough yeah
he was like a cheat code you know he
ain't gonna play college football oh
yeah he ain't playing with his brother
no he was fat did you like Michael
Vick what team is he on he was on
Virginia Tech oh he went to Virginia
Tech too oh yeah yeah that's probably
why he went are you a big uh I mean like
Alabama we only like there's no teams
they're just college football right so
are you like a college football fan yeah
what is this is it Auburn is it Alabama
Alabama
yeah have you been to one of those games
no I haven't been they look insane yeah
they look cool and I heard the uh the
the like uh what's it called beforehand
what did they do beforehand when they be
[__]
partying in the parking lot
tailgating I heard the tailgate [__] is
crazy yeah yeah in Alabama I heard that
[__] was lit bro
um yo tell me this man let's say we fast
forward 10 years from now where you hope
to be at
um [__]
the grimace
you might get hey you go listen you
might you go get you're gonna be in the
Grammy sooner sooner than that right
yeah
you state you still see yourself making
music in a decade
like you and I keep doing this [__] like
just as long as it makes as long as I
can yeah it makes sense as long as
they're [__] what you're still gonna
do it yeah because we just saw like
shits I think Snoop just I mean snoops
in his 50s Dr Dre's in his 50s like Hove
is up there like Nas
NASA you [__] us
you uh who's your who's your goats like
give me your like top three or four of
all time
it went right yeah rap rappers MC's
top three
Tupac Lil Wayne
two by the way I'm trying to think
[Music]
probably Tupac Lil Wayne
I don't know that's the two
and I like it it's what I'm listening to
I just just like how I see it who you
think is the goat yeah two for Halloween
[Music]
I like DMX DMX incredible DMs
shout out to [__] Wayne though are
you excited to watch him he's on uh he's
supposed to be co-hosting with Skip
Bayless now on Fox
um
remember that show that ain't no no no
no so Shannon sharp left and now little
Wayne is gonna be skip bayless's new
co-host on Fridays they're gonna be huh
that [__] should be crazy I ain't gonna
watch what apparently he's into sports I
mean [__] he's gonna have to be he's
gonna have to why don't you be at
everything boxing [__] he'd be
everywhere what's been have you have you
been in the big fights yet yeah I've
been in the fights I've been alive
20. you went to the tank Davis to Ryan
Garcia one went down
on the one with uh the Charlotte one
Charlotte twin I heard the tank Davis
fight the atmosphere was insane yeah
that like the best I hadn't been so I
heard like a boxer yeah it's better than
everything I heard people saying
football big fight it's got like a super
field like you had to like that you
yelling like you're the center of the
world
you obviously a big boxing fan yeah did
you watch uh what's his face the Logan
not Logan Paul Jake Paul yeah you find
ideas yeah what do you I mean that was
kind of I feel like if they would have
been some animation and they did [__]
him up for real yeah
but I knew Nate I knew he was gonna beat
Nadia but no idea we're gonna quit yeah
he don't quit then when he lose he at
like he won so he ain't really lost
UFC is the best what about wrestling you
ever watch wrestling I used to
back in the day who was your guy
um oh yeah in the Rock that's the father
that's the attitude everybody
yeah you should and then he was also
Dude Love do you remember that man yeah
he was two people who loved he was the
hippie dude yeah shout out to Mick Foley
he's a legend bro what the other man I
used to hate that name
Vince McMahon yeah yeah oh yeah Vince
McMahon's a wild boy he's also a
billionaire
yo you should go to WrestleMania it will
it's not like going to the fight I'm
sure you did yeah the one here I don't
know I was young
WrestleMania is crazy
yeah that's like that feels like you're
at some like
big time like it's almost like you're at
the Super Bowl but it's wrestling I
don't I can't remember
so you went as a kid yeah
I went to Hulk inside he has a
restaurant in Tampa terrible food but
nice guy yeah yeah Hulk Hogan is I don't
know if he's the goat
he put it on yeah like that for sure he
also
there's been some uh some some audio of
him being kind of racist before Oh you
guys I mean he said some [__] that was
kind of wild you know what I'm saying I
never heard they canceled they so he got
in trouble and they deleted all his
matches off of the WWE Network for like
a year
and then they brought him back because
it's like if you're the WWE like you're
really gonna ban Hulk Hogan for life
right he apologized obviously but yeah
Hulk Hogan you know shout out to Hulk
man yeah we gotta stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our folks
at my bookie man look my bookie NFL
season is approaching and you know what
they just added that I love is that
early cash out let's say you got a
ticket and it's looking great you can
cash out early on that ticket all right
I love it all right plus of course my
bookies got the full casino going down
and if you sign up right now using the
promo code bootleg they will give you
that first deposit bonus up to a
thousand dollars all right so head over
to my bookie ASAP um look we're at uh
NFL coming there's baseball you can
gamble on right now and of course the
full service casino blackjack with the
real dealer uh roulette craps whatever
you're into slot machines you could do
it and cash out right on my bookie all
right all you got to do is sign up with
that new promo code bootleg when you you
sign up trust me when I say it's a new
account they're going to get you that uh
first deposit bonus all right so go to
my bookie right now use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account also got to give a big shout out
to the family at kingpom
um the official sponsor of the bootleg
kit podcast so I love about King Palm is
of course it's all about organic all
right no tobacco this is straight
organic um leaves it's the only thing I
smoke out of and what I love about it is
they have these terpene infused flavor
tips and they are so good the squeezing
pops this is the watermelon
um man they got the dragon fruit they
got the grape whatever you're into trust
me they got it all right they're
available at your local smoke shop
um you can also go to kingpom.com and
use the promo code bootleg and save half
off so 50 off if you use that promo code
bootleg kingpom.com and uh man trust me
the squeeze and pop is where it's at
I've had so many people come in here and
they're like yo you squeeze and then you
get the flavor right away all right it's
and of course it's tobacco-free it's a
healthy smoke so make sure you rock with
King Palm at your local 7-Eleven your
local liquor store or go get 50 off at
kingpong.com promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview uh what
are you doing in your spare time outside
of you know running around the country
grabbing bags taking money at dice Games
Etc what do you like to do like if
you're at home
off day what's going on at the crib we
chilling I do like a white movie
what's your favorite movie ever
um
Society menace to society is a great one
paying for painful is amazing
Camron is a man killed that [__] yeah he
did I don't know medicine society that
was up there for me too right old dogs
Emma did you ever watch Don't Be a
Menace to South Central oh my God so
good such a great movie I made you like
love the Marlin Brothers bro like that
[__] is a classic yeah they really
they're really hard too yeah don't be a
menace what's crazy now but that have
you have you watched uh Cam'ron and
mesa's uh show that they do uh yeah
isn't it funny [__] hilarious for
what they say bro they be pausing
everybody that's how they do it all they
do is hit people with egregious pauses
all right oh it's so good I think they
had like a clip where they were like
they were playing like some [__] Charles
Barkley said
and he was Charles Barkley was saying
some wild [__] on TV but he was talking
about basketball right but he sounded
like literally he was saying like some
crazy [__] and Cam'ron and mace just win
it man they're they're the best would
you ever because I feel like you don't
do a lot of interviews so it's actually
dope to have you here so thank you for
coming
um I think the the one I saw was you and
uh DJ Smalls back in the day
um why is that that you have you you
don't like do a lot of [__] like that
you know what I'm saying because I feel
like you got a great personality I
didn't want to like burn myself out that
makes sense my interest I wanted to wait
like late in my career I like that I do
it so I won't be like I already did it
won't got nothing else to do yeah
so I just really wanted to wait
I respect that man yeah for you uh what
has been kind of like
the last couple of years obviously
you've been just leveling up every every
year things have been getting bigger and
bigger for you what has been the
negative of that because we always see
the positive we see you got bigger
streams bigger tours bigger money bigger
jewelry but what's the negative of the
success that you have to deal with
really like
like be like a bigger Target it's just
like hmm the bigger you get
more haters yeah it's just a bigger
sight yeah you can make it obviously you
got to move a little differently too
right the bigger you get right and
higher profile all right what's the
dumbest thing you've bought so far
lean lean yeah
that's about them
is it still really expensive I mean like
obviously
don't that's just so high it's like hot
because I mean they're like real like
the [__] they're like the activist
shit's like done like I don't even make
it they don't make that anymore yeah if
someone has activists they're lying it's
fine they might have had to put up for
years or something it's almost like wine
at that point you're like yo I got this
09 activists aged fine it'll be brown
it's brown it's not even purple no it's
gonna be brown right now
that's got to be expensive as [__] like
2001 bro my freaking parents they had uh
they had a I think from like 2004 a
prescription bottle of activists in
there in their uh oh like their medicine
cabinet I was at my parents house like
maybe like six months ago and I was
trying to find some I had I thought yes
and I pulled this [__] out and I was
like you guys know what the [__] y'all
got here um like this is probably like I
don't know a thousand dollars at least
see I don't know I never was uh I'm a
big shroom eater I hate shrooms not have
you tried them well how do you hate them
if you haven't tried them I just do what
people say it said to be hallucinating
and [__] listen we 'd hate stuff without
trying I ain't trying to loosen it I do
hate crack though I haven't tried that
oh yeah because
my real life's room
I don't know I never thought of it that
way so
shrooms is fire people have told you bad
things about shrimps anything man they
just like if you don't like weed don't
trash ones so you're not a smoker I
don't like sweet yeah have you never
been a smoker you used to why don't you
like it
paranoia yes or one day I just saw you
in paranoid I guess how you smoke a lot
though
like like that's like what about eating
weed
Edibles like Edibles would you yeah and
I ate one of them for Edibles are
terrible well I woke up huh
yeah no you'll wake up the next day
it'll put you down and then you'll wake
up and you're like yeah
[__] you know had a oh we Infuse we
Infuse what like it's like in a solution
but they put in like a wheat slushie
yeah like infused I've had the syrup
that's actually
the homie just gave me this we'll do it
try it it's like a shot
of like it's I don't know I'm gonna try
it cannabis syrup
this is supposed to be like a Five Hour
Energy Shot but it's
this is sweet yeah yeah but I wouldn't
the thing is you like supposed to pour
this into a Sprite or something oh yeah
yeah now I've never done a weed infused
Slusher you have Yeah by mistake oh
that's [__] up gave you that and laid
out on food you shouldn't be friends
with them anymore if they gave me no I
asked for it or I'm thinking they come
with the food thing the solution but I'm
also saying fuse on it I ain't read it
oh hell no then I had to go report the
next week so you had to did you have to
clean up your piss yeah yeah and then
I'm like yeah I tell my PO right now I'm
throwing my mistake ain't gonna believe
that
so did you tell your PO he ain't piss me
so he was also were you just on colors
which but what where I'm from they do
this I was on some nice A little cool
probation they don't do the color [__]
okay okay because the color is like you
just don't know if you wake up you don't
even know yeah yeah this one like yeah
yo trying to clean up your piss before a
piss test is extremely stressful
activity yeah that is true it'll have
you drinking some wild shots on some
[__] yeah and I ain't even had to pee
and it didn't even make you piss after
no I'm somebody I ain't even text me so
you drank all that for nothing all right
that's what sucks about weed is two
weeks if you if unless you drink all
that [__]
and then you know they say you drink a
lot of water I had my you know how many
times my cousins are all been on
probation my freaking uncles I as a
child have pissed into pill bottles for
them I'm talking at least 50 times
I go in the bathroom I'm pissing in a
pill bottle I'm taking it to my cousin
and then they go and they they'll
microwave it right before they gotta
leave the house so it's like right kind
of like room temperature by the time
they get there and they pour that [__] I
mean unless the PO is watching obviously
but a lot of back then they didn't watch
so like I was pissing for everybody I
was really tripping because I should
have been charging for my pictures
did you ever have to use someone else's
pee
uh yeah now our offensive
the same day oh [__] you're an AP like
yo let me get some of that yeah the only
thing is it's like you get caught it's
like yeah it's a strike for sure right
or is it a violation or why does that
work I don't know I don't think
everybody won't do too much they might
just gonna make you still get pissed you
gotta try some true match they catch I'm
gonna get with some shrooms try them one
day
I probably try to can okay no I have
some candy oh yeah yeah listen it's
better than lean
hell no
that [__] stink no no no the candy it
doesn't smell it again no you don't have
it ain't that [__]
technically yes oh yeah yeah do you like
mushrooms on your pizza me either that's
the same thing I mean it's all a fungus
right yeah so technically you're right
mushrooms come from [__] yeah yeah yes
but
I mean look all of our [__] is uh buried
and there's a fertilizer that's all
[__] horseshit fertilizer I think is
put into the into the ground to make the
the ground real you know the soil and
[__] nutrient
and when you back up if you go to Home
Depot right now you'll buy a bag of
fertilizer that's just [__] bro
so yeah I mean you know mushrooms are
[__] for sure you gotta give it a shot
for you like have you ever tried to get
off a lean
yeah is it tough yeah
it I heard it tastes good I've never did
it
I heard like I had like a homie who was
like he was like real bloated dude right
drink lean every [__] day finally got
off it took him a long time
within like six months he looked like a
new human being but it had to be because
he got rid of that lean good see I got a
lingo without drinking lean that's a
problem no I just [__] I'm just white
and old bruh it's called being a father
at 36. yeah they said when you get that
bill at 30. you can't get that
[__] I've been trying I swear
like I said don't come on you ain't
lying bro I've been trying bruh I'm 36
and I'm still [__] the gut is just
I'm not like a fat dude you won't get
the surgery right again I ain't [__]
Batman Kevo bruh I ain't getting no
goddamn BBL I can't do that would you
get a BBL like a a fake six-pack
mm-hmm
nah
nah you wouldn't
I respect that
ain't nothing wrong with it huh
whatever makes you happy right right if
you're getting a six-pack makes you
happy if you're getting you know the oh
I said whatever you're into whatever
yeah if it helps your self-esteem if it
helps you feel happier when you wake up
all right damn you gotta do it 100 who
do you think you have the best chemistry
with when it comes to working with
another artist like who do you think
you're just like you guys are just about
a thousand percent you just love the
chemistry y'all got in the studio
together on the record
get a cup maybe a couple people who are
they
[Music]
cap baby
yeah
what's the yachty studio sesh like
because he's hilarious I've been
watching I just watched this podcast did
you see his podcast he did with sexy red
I didn't see that one I'm so fast
it's fun oh my God it's good I just saw
this I saw two clips I saw uh
I saw the one that dropped today she was
her baby she her baby daddy was calling
for prison and then little yachty
interviewed him oh okay well I did yeah
it was good
so you what is it what is it like
recording with baby because I I was
talking to uh Eve J Cole's guy he was
giving me some insight on when he hopped
on cold [__] like how just like he's
like an alien like he's so good you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah is it like
that being in the studio when we're just
like this is this [__] is crazy like
yeah he good it great
he freestyle at first then you go in
there you clean it up yeah that's just
crazy because most people like you said
you'll do the [__] your hum to like
really go in and just for heal for
everyone to do
yeah I have six verses
eating Batman raps she's verses and
let's see which one to keep
wow yeah he'll put pieces like it might
he might grab one from there one forever
but yeah he just recorded out a little
one song So six verses for one record
and then yeah yeah his favorite parts
from each verse and then we got the
super verse Oh that [__] is crazy I've
never heard nobody doing that you'll be
doing that here or something that [__]
wow he might play your song he might
play with that song again play that
[__] again three different verses and
they only use one of them that [__]
crazy are you gonna do a deluxe for your
project
nah I'm just gonna do another tape for
like three months in three months yeah
someone come out to oh you ain't playing
yeah you ain't playing
hey we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our folks at Odd Socks baby
shout out to Odd Socks man the most
comfortable socks in the world Listen
they got all the licenses if you love
chips you know what I'm saying they got
the Funyuns they got the goddamn Doritos
uh they got Godfather was double by Odd
Socks is not only is it the most
comfortable sock in the world that you
could put on your feet but they also
just introduce their draws that's right
we got Odd Socks Basics underwear right
here which are amazing so if you um
if you just like that clean cut you know
we got the black ones or
if you're a fan of
a little bit of the uh Reese's you know
what I'm saying
look go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you'll
save 20 off at checkout the most
comfortable socks in the world they got
the basics these are a pair of the
basics these are oh they're just so
comfortable dude like trust me when I
say all right if you're into wrestling
if you're into Transformers Power
Rangers goddamn Pepsi Coke they got both
you know what I'm saying shout out to
Odd Socks oddsocksofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout also got a shout out to the
family at Blue chew that's right it's
hot as hell outside what does that have
to do with Bluetooth I haven't decided
yet but I do know if you're uh dealing
with erectile dysfunction or maybe your
thing ain't thinking like it should be
thanging you know what I'm saying get
that Bluetooth same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis yes all right but it's
getting straight to your door in a very
discreet package no doctor's
appointments no doctor's visits all
right it's all online bluetooth.com all
right and this was dope about Bluetooth
uh one uh it makes your dick work like
it's never worked before we're just
being honest imagine like Barry Bonds 71
home run season but the dick form that's
how you're gonna be feeling when you're
on these blue shoes all right trust me
when I say it's a chewable form they
just drop their mint chewables as well
um there's so much to go down with
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg and they'll send you your first
month
for free yes you asking me does
Bluetooth work of course it does find
out for yourself for free bluetooth.com
promo code bootleg all right go get you
a month of Bluetooth for free
and thank me later your wife will be
thinking me your girl will be thanking
me your dick will be thinking me you
know what I mean all right let's get
back to the interview
is it easy to record on the road or not
you just focus on performing
it's my heart it might harder you doing
the bus bus still no we're going to the
studio yeah well then yeah yeah well
that's what we'd be having like breaks
off I've seen them just every day right
right so we here where we go we book
Studio
every city yeah because you still gotta
record
yeah the uh that's the only thing that
was like you're like a random City like
I don't know if the studio is fire I
don't know who the [__] gonna be there
all right I don't know what security is
like
it was just BS we like broke the whole
student take the whole building yeah
that's how you got to do it yeah
um yo what it's for you man what's next
for you can you see yourself ever acting
can you see yourself ever having like
your own imprint where you're signing an
artist like what is
I'm gonna start signing some Waters
that's something you want to do yeah
is there anything you've learned from
baby being like a CEO that you would
apply to your own [__]
yeah I'm just learning that's where we
go yeah he'd be on see some a lot of
stuff though
yeah he's still learning too is it
important for you to try to find artists
from Alabama are you down to sign
someone from wherever from oil yeah
for real for sure Alabama though you
gotta put on man and what is the food
like in Mobile like what's the Food Spot
there like oh yes good ass food
is it like soul food or whatever
so if we pull up where are you taking me
bro taking your huts chicken hearts
chicken taking out a food stackless
well some takes to that
Godfathers if you like pizza love pizza
um
I'm trying to think still we get it
anybody again alligator over there
alligator yeah have you had alligator
yeah no that shit's fire
hey Frau good frog I haven't had frog I
got a friend we just went somewhere and
he ordered frog legs yeah she said like
chicken they got too many veins yeah I
can't do what you like this when I take
a fruit alligator yeah but but the
difference is it was like nuggets
so it was like a breaded alligator
nugget nah I hope I could eat it then
like that I can't eat it just soon
really good yeah yeah I don't I don't
like to me the Frog thing you see the
frog legs and you're like man that's a
[__] Lake ah yeah but it looked like
a chicken though see I if I know it's a
frog I ain't [__] with that right
what you know it's a chicken
but I see I'm my Society has
desensitized me it made me okay with
eating a chicken all right the happiest
like a frog could be my homie yeah I
mean I got a pet Frog as a kid yeah I
was really cute one with my frog a
daycare oh really what I had a pet frog
named Fat Joe I think my [__] name uh
little TJ or something did uh because yo
taking care of a frog is tough for
people don't know this [__] cage can
smell right did you ever have a turtle
though
in the top
oh we probably died from starvation and
from
he probably ran out of breath well he
might die from both of them and I fought
up 99 with Jimmy Jimmy the Frog yeah see
I see that's why I can't eat a frog you
can't eat Jimmy can't you can't eat
Jimmy I don't have a pet [__] cow bro
I'll eat a burger you know what I'm
saying yeah no but the alligator nuggets
if you ever go to Houston go to Papados
and they got alligator nuggets them
shits are amazing I'm gonna try one
though not bad yeah intro I've never
tried you know what another thing that I
tried that I didn't see it and I was
straight into eating no not squirrel
that's some Alabama [__] for sure uh
rattlesnake
nah
I didn't know it was and then I ate it
and I was like what's that chicken
that's different though like that's a
snake I said oh yeah
a rattlesnake bro they'd be serving that
[__] you had a squirrel no ain't no
Adam's World well I know for each
squirrels do they eat that [__] in
Alabama
I heard somebody squirrel for
did you see the Alabama fight that
happened on the on the pier yeah
somebody sent me that the other day this
is one of the craziest fights we've ever
captured on video in American history
what and it happened in your home state
yeah that shit's insane
the chair man that chair the chair is
going to live in infamy forever there
you go yeah yeah
that my guy was out there like [__]
like mankind bro in 98 WWE just cracking
fools with the chair bro
100 what's your uh what's your favorite
song on Ben one
um what is a change
oh yeah I think I like teleport Jenkins
and uh
[Music]
teleport attack and oh free games I free
game my favorite song okay
yo what I love about you is that like
you're bringing back like
you're doing like dope r b
records like
because you have records that are like
very reminiscent like we were talking
about earlier like
to just like when I was growing up you
know what I'm saying and I feel like a
lot of a lot of male artists for
whatever reason right now
just ate applying
themselves into making records like that
anymore right like I'm not a Russian a
lot of Russian is happening a lot of
just half-assed hooks yeah they're just
going we're trying to get it out there
and you're like putting out records
where I'm like oh this is like
this is a record right like like for you
like how do you feel about the music
industry right now because it feels like
the women are kind of running [__]
low-key you know what I mean it is
running they're killing it and I always
say they're making records they're like
making records catchy ass songs
but the women they for sure running the
guy right now
their children yeah it's kind of crazy
for you though like do you want to be
that guy because I think back to like my
50 Cent 50 Cent always has them like you
had some gangster [__] but I also have
that [__] for you like for the ladies
for the is that something you want to
make sure you're always uh you I always
gotta make something for the female yeah
I always got to
100 how's how's your female fan base
pretty pretty crazy it's super crazy huh
you must need some wild DMs
did I have whatever do you want get like
are they your DM's just [__] flooded
non-stop yeah
damn it damn me some crazy yeah
crazy deal like what though like just
random nudes not internet like
[__] like Frozen say some crazy [__]
[__] damn you want to say I said
for her
he was dead serious he was dead ass
serious did you reply yeah
like imagine hitting up someone like you
and being like hey man
I just need you to come to my living
room what and like my daughter is six
months old
can't even speak I just need you to
perform for her this is a serious I have
zero money for you do me that solid sign
Jimbo from Montgomery Alabama
no hell no no would you do like like
have you done any of these crazy private
parties yet we're like you [__]
you'll get paid like
three or four or five times as much as
you usually get paid but you're
performing for like
you know I mean dude I went to the
[__] Fanatics party in in Vegas with
a baby and that [__] was insane have you
done any of that kind of [__] like any
other questions
or something like that what about like a
like a football players some [__] bar
mitzvah or anything nah you got to do
bar mitzvahs I don't know what that is
it's like a Jewish boy's birthday oh
yeah so then bar mitt that bar mitzvah
monies it's serious right it's 100 all
right uh so you say we're getting
another project in three months for sure
for sure
you ain't slowing down man uh so
tomorrow's over and you're getting right
back to it yeah then I'm going on to
your own tour I'm going to run my own
tour after that who you taking on tour
with you know what I got to see I ain't
figured out yet yeah I Gotta See
anybody from Alabama Maybe
yeah
yeah I think uh I think you should go on
a little vacation first
get off tour go to go vacation somewhere
bro like take a week to yourself
you gotta you gotta rest a little bit
London is cool but like I feel like if
you went to London
you wouldn't really relax
why is it because London is lit bro it's
like going to New York when people say
yeah but it's like imagine saying you
went on vacation in New York
you're oh that's different I just want
to go to yeah you should you want to go
to London yeah you want you need to go
somewhere or you could just sit on the
beach and get [__] up with that [__]
kind of something where you gotta go
but they gotta you get that you
flattered then they gotta drive you on
the boat to the island
yeah that just sounds like a bunch of
places but yes the Bahamas Bali
um it might be if that's what you need
to go to that might be it or It's gotta
relax take a lady friend chill walk away
yourself all right go get [__] up get
fat eat a bunch of food you shouldn't
eat then get back to the Grind All Right
100 man
um hey man uh anything else coming up
for you obviously how many more dates
are on the tour
[Applause]
um
20 more got a lot more touring left to
do
um album is out new I'm out new album on
the way hey would you and no cap ever do
a joy novel yeah we did one but we got
another we're gonna do that yeah I
didn't know you guys did one yeah you're
doing yeah we're doing it kind of um
you guys would run it back yeah we're
gonna do what about you who is there an
R B artist you would ever do a whole
album with like some like Best of Both
Worlds Jay-Z R Kelly type [__] uh
yeah yeah
it's a cup it's a lot for that dude like
r b with who's your favorite RB artist
give me a couple names I want you to
take one and then you know piss somebody
off man Aaliyah
she would shout out to her that would be
a tough collab project
Ashanti
um
great to see her and Nelly back together
Brent
good for him
hey
young blue heart you know I'm blue yeah
blue super hot keep it home team yeah
um well there it is man look go get the
new album there's lots of Records on it
going crazy right being one go go check
this guy out on tour with babies going
crazy all over the country yeah
um appreciate your time bro I know you
don't do a lot of interviews so I
appreciate you pulling up today
Riley Rodriguez my guy boom dog fired
hey what up man uh you just watched
another episode of the blue black cat
podcast brought to you by hard Dean baby
shout out to the family at hardean don't
forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
hardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they're gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at hardine in Las
Vegas the number one dispensary in the
world all right and we are so proud to
be partners with them so shout out to
hardine go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine